[Music]
Katy Perry kissed an Idol contestant and
he so it did not like it
have you kissed a girl and liked it no
I've never been in a relationship really
I can't kiss the girl without being in
relationship that's how 19 year old
Benjamin Glaser's American Idol audition
started during Monday night's episode on
the cheek he didn't even make the smush
[Applause]
do you have any any water by chance it's
just I kind of wasn't expecting it
the Oklahoma native was seemingly shook
up and after singing got an O from all
three judges I think you're a bit rushed
and maybe that was because I sped up
your BPM of the heartbeat and now
Benjamin tells the New York Times how
upset he was by the smooch quote I was
raised in a conservative family and I
was uncomfortable immediately I wanted
my first kiss to be special
[Music]
et chatted with the Idol judges ahead of
the season premiere they mentioned a few
weird things happened in the audition
room one where contestant may have been
crushing on Katie its flattery first
sure but like but it's not about us
we're just like here to help and support
and to truly find an American Idol and
that's the thing I think we all signed
up for this is like American Idol can
make actually someone's dreams come true
yes Yugi has reached out to Katie's rep
for comments